it was one of the last century's darkest
and most shameful periods a genocide
that killed as many as a million people
that the world didn't do enough to stop
for this Yankee Booga the man accused of
bankrolling and organizing much of it
has been in hiding and on the run ever
since for a quarter of a century when
Hutu militia fanned out across Rwanda to
slaughter their political rivals and
ethnic Tutsis they were answering a call
to murder broadcast by Philistine kibou
goes radio station it accused of buying
many of the machetes there used to hack
their victims to death and finance their
deadly efforts he was finally hunted
down here in an apartment near Paris
even more than a quarter of a century on
and it's possible when national
jurisdictions work with the
international justice system to bring
somebody to justice who has has been
wanted for all those years and has not
yet been found now the case can be heard
and the evidence can be tested and the
victims can obviously be heard in terms
of their testimony but the defendant too
can be heard may have been the most
wanted suspect for the genocide he's
accused of financing but have been able
to live in France it seems four years
under an assumed name in a statement in
the International residual mechanism for
criminal tribunal said his arrest is a
reminder that those responsible for
genocide can be brought to account even
26 years after their crimes for
international justice kibou goes arrest
demonstrates that we can succeed when we
have the international community's
support
kibou Gers expected to be handed over to
stand trial at the tribunal after the
operation that involved ten different
countries he was indicted in his absence
in 1997 on seven different counts of
genocide the land is still honor the
memory of the hundreds of thousands who
died in the three months of massacres 26
years ago they've welcomed the news of
Kabu Gers arrest but know that even
after all this time other key suspects
still remain on the run Dominik Waghorn
Sky News